welcome to this video what am I going to
let's play something else MN cm 7 8 9
from Brazil to 256 rated going for them
philidor he's playing on a quick f3
setup and I'm going to push on the
queenside so that long castles as son is
discouraged
trying to get get quick play down I give
this check stir Scott I don't know but I
maybe i can i can take first trying to
activate pieces with both c5 Callie
let's check first so that it probably
needs to play Quincy one don't really
believe he can sacrifice with king of
two okay skank we have a queen trade and
now d phi if this was my idea opening up
the position now
ok this is a potentially nice Bishop
here on b6 that prevents castling
yeah 96 should I castle yeah probably
now it looks a bit strange on ahead but
i think i will i will kick this piece
out again got 95 is one possible idea to
get rid of the night bishops our last
night's you for always okay but I need
to be a bit bit quicker
yes yeah this end game check it's a bit
bit worse for me because because of the
slightly Wicked Queen side and the
bishop on ahead it's a it's not much fun
okay but let's see how to defend this
okay if he takes yeah okay if he takes
on d5 it's the worst is over so he won't
won't take down it's pretty clear okay
yeah this is just just a very strange
move why would you give up your bishops
okay we can try to go to d3 and and so
on play for the be football but yeah
that's not not really troubling like
okay anyway let's go checking age to
your ok why not or is it trapped no it's
not trapped yeah now i just have an end
game with two bishops against bishop
annoyed
night
okay and I need to activate this a eight
bishop after all this is the defined
defining Bishop of the bishop am ok
yeah there are not many points on the
board
intending now okay so was treating this
intending to give the the chicken Ted
Bishop as one
now Jackie for me was a frog threat
it's a bit of a bluff because b5 Bishop
before but this is just the draw of
course I want to win
Saudi form
yeah prepare gphone
check
I wanted to get the Bishop to e3 because
night III would have attacked d5 so this
is the quickest way to advance check
and H 2 wins the peace um probably some
matter of precision here
of course I need the King
hmm yeah maybe he's getting his getting
to this to draw
check
time warning triumphal should G to
pinning check
check
check
check now check it's not much time
check Wow can manage checkmate Wow yeah
of course I had already spotters and
game with some in precise moves here I I
don't think that it should be a win
somehow what does he manage to go see
phone yeah I wasn't so sure about h2
maybe I had something better him better
timed if he gets to exchange my last
porn this was the general problem there
were so few pawns left maybe I'm I could
have done something something better I
don't know when the way it it went down
it was some he can he can always place
your phone and get to get rid of check
my last poem and this was just a cat
luckily was something check getting
caught up in and pins k and this okay 20
about 20 something moves that took 22 mm
and two bishops is much easier than
bishop at night bishop at night and 20
seconds able manage i can do it in about
a minute but not 20 seconds alright
thanks for watching
you